prot casimir tu m'as l'air bien gai
aujourd'hui oui ça fait un jeu prend
1 franc par ce parce que tu es gay non
non mais parce que tu es rentré dans mon
musée du chapeau eh ben tu vois la télé
francs pour une fois je veux bien ces
deux n'est pas feinte alors attention la
visite commence à suivez le guide à à
l'oser alors ici un premier chapeau avec
une plume rouge à rennes ici un autre
très beau château avec plein de plumes
noires par ici la visite à suivez le
guide a ici d'autres chars sont simples
mais très beau quand même avec son
casque au récit suivez le guide a ici à
notre caste et deux chapeaux noirs ou là
la visite est terminée n'oubliez pas le
guide a parce qu'en plus tu as le toupet
de me réclamer un tournoi ah oui parce
que les enfants étaient pour le
directeur du musée c'est à dire moi oui
et maintenant je te demande un pourboire
pour le guide sert en moyenne aux désolé
casimir tu n'auras pas de pourboire le
feu tu as pas fait un véritable travail
de guide ce qui est intéressant quand on
visite un musée sont les explications
que peut donner le guide les petits
détails amusants au sujet de chacun des
objets qu'ils présentent je ne vois pas
ce qu'il peut y avoir donc ravir des
chapeaux ce sont des chapeaux casimir du
brochet pas moi tiens nous dire quels
sont les métiers qui représentent
chacune de ses coiffures ah bon parce
que chacune de ses coiffures en
présentant métier mais évidemment hier
j'ai appelé les enfants ils ont aidé au
nom ne serait pas la peine non messieurs
merci les enfants vont venez venez tous
casimir a besoin de vous vous allez
expliquer à casimir comment s'appelle
chacune de ses coiffures et quels sont
les métiers qu'ils représentent d'accord
et vous souciez vous
alors si si
c'est un casque de pompier rien j'aurai
pas deviner ce chapeau
non c'est pas chapeau de curé
pas de cuisinier par deux moines c'est
une toque de juge le juge à neuf c'est
pas pareil elle te mettrais bien une
marche à votre cowboys c'est un jeu
c'est un nom de fruit
c'est un chapeau melon chapeau cerise et
bien chapeau pastèque tu sais on
charbonneau voilà oui moi je sais c'est
le chapeau quand même un petit bonhomme
qui a des petites moustaches et une
canne qui marche comme ça comment
s'appelle-t-il
non ces charlots charlot charmant vous
gagnez ces charlots les offres ni la
visite continue par ici il n'a d'autre
part issiémou quand celui ci
ni de juge ni de majorettes ça s'appelle
une wii et s'appelle une mitre
de prêtres d'évêques
ensuite celui ci les enfants
tous très bien cuisinier c'est une union
s'appelle une toque de cuisinier
exactement c'est un casque de motard eh
ben vous l'académie je crois qu'avec
toutes ces explications tu feras un très
bon jeu un très bon guide au oui non
mais je suis furieux parce que
maintenant ça ne sert plus à rien tout
le monde à visiter mon musée sans payer
casimir quasi nul mais que tarik filmé
tutu vraiment trop coléreux
j'en ai assez
françois laisse moi tranquille
le cospar steam monsieur casimir est en
colère mais devient insupportable en son
nom j'essaie de le câliner jugé que ces
murs qu'est ce qui ne va pas j'ai un
problème
[Musique]
je voudrais bien savoir comment il faut
faire pour devenir sage être toujours
aubigny sens comme les enfants sur les
images
surtout quand on est
moi avec des rêves plein la tête
on a des gestes maladroits s'il te plaît
dix mois la recette
en vérité et plaisait
[Musique]
et gagner
tu veux bien sage sans savoir et vert
les gens autour de toi
c'est merveilleux
m
bonjour à pau
m'arrive de temps en temps de partir en
claquant la porte ce n'est pas que je
sois méchant c'est la colère qui
m'emporte
certes il arrive que je
un gars avec les meilleurs de mes
copains et chapeau sans crier gare
vérité fait plaisir
c'est gagner que de bien seuls son
savoir m
tu es borrat de rendre à venise en photo
c'est râpé 1
[Musique]
sous
je veux bien essayer
pour diminuer mes bêtises se faire
plaisir au monde entier ce sera dur pas
que tu dis
les autres
en somme un secret mathieu du snop et
leurs acteurs julie mademoiselle futé
compte aussi parfois des erreurs
bien savoir comment il peut faire pour
devenir sage d'être toujours obéi sans
comme les enfants sur les images
aja surtout quand on est homo avec des
rêves
on a des gestes mal
mais j'ai bien compris la rue